from Flickr. Go over to the right-hand side,
grab Flickr from the list of options,
drag it into the timeline,
and put it where you'd like it to go,
and it immediately goes out to Flickr and starts pulling in
images based on the tags. Now, my developers
really like ponies, and so they've set that as the default tag.
Let's try something else,
maybe something a bit more relevant to today.
Now here are live images being pulled straight from the feed.
If you come and watch this a week from now,
this will be completely different,
dynamic, just like the web, and just like the web,
everything is sourced, so click your link,
and you go straight to Flickr and see the source image.
Everything you've seen today is built with the basic
building blocks of the web: HTML, CSS and JavaScript.
That means it's completely remixable. It also means
there's no proprietary software. All you need
is a web browser.
So imagine if every video that we watched on the web
worked like the web, completely remixable,
linked to its source content, and interactive
for everyone who views it.
I think Popcorn could change the way that we tell stories on
the web, and the way we understand the world we live in.
Thank you. (Applause)